[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois elisabeth de
feydeau la versaillaise
mais pas que elisabeth de feydeau
bonjour est sûre véronique merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
vous êtes beaucoup de choses vous êtes
historienne du parfum experte en parfum
vous êtes conseillère auprès de grandes
marques de parfums peut-être la
créatrice d'une société qui s'appelle
arty fragrance qui propose des bougies
parfumées inspirée par versailles bien
sûr et vous êtes aussi auteur et un prof
à visible qu'à l'école de parfums à
versailles et auteur alors aujourd'hui
c'est l'auteur qui m'intéresse voilà
parce que vous sortez un nouveau livre
aux éditions plon
un livre qui s'intitule et dans la
fameuse collection des dictionnaires
amoureux donc dictionnaire amoureux du
parfum que voici
tout frais non juste de sauver si le 18
mars 18 mars
voilà alors déjà quels sont les
commentaires quand on vous propose un
tel travail donc de décrire un
dictionnaire amoureux
évidemment votre choisi quelqu'un de
passionné et d'experts en la matière
donc voila vous est-ce qu'on vous donne
des consignes des directives non de sin
nombre de mots est ce qu'il faut faire
toutes les lettres
comment ça se passe alors en fait c'est
une véritable récréation d'auteur parce
que le seul finalement brief que l'on
reçoit c'est qu'il faut être amoureux
voilà vous êtes amoureuse en sujet voilà
donc évidemment essayer de couvrir
toutes les lettres de préférence dont on
a tout de même aussi un nombre de signes
à respecter parce que on pourrait en
faire trois tomes donc celui-là il est
pas mais c'est quand même assez oui
c'est la prime minimum ça
non je pense que l'éditeur aurait
souhaité que ce soit un tout petit peu
plus court mais bon un moment donné
c'est vrai quand on est quand on aime on
ne compte pas mais il faut quand même un
petit peu contexte où elle a donc fausse
restreint des puits faut vraiment avoir
comme ligne de suite de se dire qu'est
ce que j'ai mais pourquoi est ce que
j'ai envie de parler de ça et comment
j'ai envie d'en parler avec amour et
passion mais non sans raison quand même
d'accord et libertés et liberté on a une
totale liberté
ça c'est vraiment très peur même quand
on raconte donc à mots choisis
on n'est pas obligé de tout raconter
voyais et à son encyclopédie qu est l ac
vraiment précédemment j'avais écrit un
ouvrage à la collection de bouquins qui
est beaucoup plus encyclopédique
scientifique ou là au contraire on nous
demande d'être très détaché du sujet
c'est à dire de le traiter de façon très
objectif ne plus le plus history
exhaustivement possible aussi et alors
que là non on est dans le subjectif
c'est vraiment le prisme c'est vous quoi
mais ça c'est très agréable
puis c'est pas si facile que ça dans le
fond au début on pense que ça va être de
récréation total mais non ces demandes
est aussi une discipline dans dans
l'écriture et dites moi juste pour en
aparté donc le livre chez ces boues chez
bouquins comme ça s'appelle ça c'était
les parfums histoire anthologie
dictionnaires etc paru en 2011 d'un
loyer à 10 ans différents mois la rue
vous les avez commencé en tant qu'auteur
avec le parfumeur de marie antoinette
gillet farjon exactement ça fait en 2005
sort en pocket one mais c'est vrai oui à
monsieur madoff via une deuxième vie à
jean yole bravo et moi je vous avais
reçu aussi pour leur monde et garlin oui
et l'agrandissement du parfum chez
larousse voilà mais d'autres encore
wonder prolixe très bien alors revenons
à nos moutons à savoir ce dictionnaire
c'est une collection qui existe depuis
97 ça fait vingt-quatre ans oui voilà
qui marche très bien
oui et c'est un peu un cadeau que vous
fait vous êtes contente s'imagine ah bah
ça a été formidable que c'était un rêve
c'était vraiment un rêve j'étais grand
de collectionneuse finalement de ses
ouvrages aimait beaucoup j'aimais
énormément la façon dont il est écrit et
c'est vrai pour moi je m'étais dit c'est
un jour je suis choisi pour écrire le
dictionnaire amoureux du parfum ce
serait un bonheur total
ah oui absolument et donc quand un jour
le téléphone a sonné j'y croyais pas
quoi j'étais vraiment très heureuse
d'avoir été choisie parce qu'on est
choisissez un peu voilà ça les a
présenté la wii est adéquat
alors à quoi je ne sais pas s'il a la
plus belle alors très bien en tout cas
bravo
dites moi quels sont vos mots préférés
aux bonzes de la pression celle qui vous
correspond alors le plus alors moi je
dirais je commencerai par amour ouais
parce que d'abord je trouve que j'aime
l'idée d'être amoureuse je trouve que
net est amoureuse aussi bien d'une
personne bien sûr que d'être amoureux
d'un lieu d'un d'une musique on est
amoureux une odeur voilà et je trouve
que le mot amour
donc si on en revient à la racine latine
de et ross il est tellement riche parce
qu'il n'ya pas que l'amour l'amour entre
deux maîtres il ya aussi cet amour
philanthropique ya aussi cet amour de la
vie à dont je trouve que c'est vraiment
un mot très riche et j'aime énormément
aussi cet état amoureux d'accord et
alors dites moi on parle beaucoup de la
madeleine de proust dont en général on
peut souvent cette question aux
écrivains alors vous au niveau de
olfactivement parlant je veux dire
quelle quelle est votre odeur qui vous
rappellent l'enfance un souvenir joyeux
la fleur d'oranger la fleur d'oranger
qui est en plus une fleur du bonheur qui
est très liée au bonheur comme je le
raconte au mot bonheur et pour moi c'est
très important parce que c'est le
souvenir de ma grand-mère qui avaient
été levées en tunisie et
qui avait gardé de sa tunisie natale ce
goût des épices des odeurs et aussi de
cette fleur d'oranger ce qu'elles
avaient vécu dans un champ de fleurs
d'oranger prenne fin d'orange et plus
exactement et en tunisie et elle parfume
et toujours ces desserts et
particulièrement la le gâteau au
chocolat elle avait un gâteau royal qui
s'appelait était délicieux elle le
parfait naffer de ranger donc pour moi
la fleur d'oranger c'est vraiment
l'enfance mer
et puis aussi ce cette boisson qu elle
nous donnait le soir et qui est après
j'ai appris que ça s'appelle le café
blanc du liban et qui est digestif qui
est très bon qu'on donne d'ailleurs au
liban et en orient en général le soir
qui est digestif c'est de l'eau de fleur
d'oranger avec de l'eau chaude tout
simplement brillant
et c'est absurde ou conseil véronique
cerveau le cerveau ou ça vous calme ça
vous appelle à vous permet d'y gérer et
c'est merveilleux donc moi la fleur
d'oranger
je suis c'est la maison de prusse et on
en a tous et est quelquefois des
inconsciente anglais on n'est pas encore
identifié puis tout d'un coup on va
sentir quelque chose ou un parfum et
tout d'un coup on est immédiatement dans
le lieu est dans l'époque on avait vécu
en est transporté ouais c'est le tapis
volant ouais extra d'accord et je me
demandais est-ce qu' une odeur que vous
aimez particulièrement qui serait un peu
inavouables c'est beaucoup dire mais
puisque c'est subjectif quelque chose
que vous trouvez très odorant très très
agréable et que d'autres disent mais non
c'est dégoûtant c'est possible oui alors
c'est les on dit souvent en parfumerie
qui a pas de vérité c'est à de bonnes et
de mauvaises odeurs on aime une odeur
avec son vécu puisque si vous voulez le
le nerf olfactif qui qui nous permet
donc de s'en tenir et relier directement
la partie la plus archaïque du cerveau
qu'on appelle la partie limbique et
qu'elle siège des émotions
donc quand vous enregistrer une odeur de
façon consciente ou inconsciente ou
l'enregistrer toujours avec sa sensation
physique émotionnel aussi donc par
exemple
vous allez vous promener en forêt ça
sent un peu le champignon la mousse etc
et puis c'est un moment très agréable
vous avez une conversation merveilleuse
vous êtes avec une personne que vous
aimez forcément l'odeur de champignons
vous allez aimer si une autre personne
fait la même promenade mais que elle
elle s'est cassé la figure qu'il ya une
dispute que machin forcément l'odeur
qu'elle aura enregistré en même temps
est associé à une sensation désagréable
et il n'aimera pas cette odeur de
champignons de mousse et passe donc
c'est tout le temps et sa future ou
lasagnes alors généralement la revue
psychology
elle va détester le dos de cheval ou
alors elle peut ou alors il faudra
qu'elle l'est du kiss et il faudrait
qu'elle apprenne à l'aimer et ça a été
des odeurs qui sont un peu plus
difficile à aimer mais que l'on apprend
à aimer comment faire et bien là et on
sait que c'est comme le d'éducation du
goût si vous vous les voyez par exemple
beauchemin les huîtres n'ont pas
forcément quelque chose qu'on peut aimer
dans cette année manquant commence
doucement et en voilà et ben entre
décideurs qui sont comme ça un peu plus
compliqué un peu plus difficile là c'est
vrai par exemple moi je pense vos notes
animales le muscle ton cas lambres gris
la civette de castoréum qui sont des
notes extraordinaire en parfumerie ou
bien mettre cette rémanence est associé
avec d'autres choses qui vont bien sûr
associé avec autre chose quand vous les
sentez brut comme ça vous dites mais
c'est horrible ça sent la bête ça sent
si c'est très difficile à aimer quoi et
finalement quand vous apprenez à
domestiquer aussi l'odeur un peu sauvage
nous apprécier au contraire les notes de
chaleur de pau la profondeur et vous
êtes peu à peu dans cette espèce de
reconnaissance amoureuse de loder et moi
par exemple la fameuse à n'aimait pas du
tout le tort de la rose
non mais c'est vrai j'aimais pas la
route alors j'ai bien cool donne la rose
dans les jardins en peluche et marraine
d'une rose donc quand même il faut
mieux que j'aime cette odeur ben oui
j'adorerais l'odeur dans les jardins de
la rose mais en revanche la rose en
parfumerie je détestais cette odeur j'ai
trouvé sa vieille dame un petit peu et
en fait j'ai compris que c'est parce que
pour moi c'était associés aux toilettes
riz c'est à dire toutes ces notes de
crack son appel et toi lectrice est
d'ailleurs en fait les parfums un peu
d'hygiène et notamment en angleterre
qu'est ce que vous avez contre l'hygiène
mais moi j'aime bien me gêne mais c'est
en angleterre
les parfums le parfum de la rose est
très souvent associée aux notes de talc
de lait hydratant et c est moi j'avais
horreur de ça je trouvais ça m'est
vraiment mièvre et ça me rappelait mes
séjours en angleterre plus vieux et
voilà et du coup je n'ai pas et peu un
peu je me suis mise à aimer la rose et
surtout maintenant fait des nouvelles
rose en parfumerie qui sont
exceptionnels qui sont voilà lié à des
vous avez réussi votre d'orange et voilà
et maintenant j'aime la rose a joué en
plus j'ai appris que dans mon parfum
préféré il y avait de la rose ont forcé
dans l'eure et bleu voilà les détails le
gars est extra et dites moi pour
terminer comment dire ou comment se
passe leur offre aujourd'hui sur l'offre
du parfum et qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quoi
alors bas depuis je parle beaucoup du
19e de l'âge d'or du parfum du design on
a l'impression que c'est quand même
début 20e c'est ces trois jeunes ont
quand même c'est différent il ya eu un
âge d'or si vous voulez au moment de la
naissance du par la parfumerie moderne
qui qu'a eu lieu au 19e et c'est vrai
qu'un peu plus tard le temps que tout ça
s'assimile etc
ces années 90 des années 20 aux années
50 c'était exceptionnel on annonce au
romanesque en diable aviation et on a
encore les plus grands succès qui existe
toujours shalimar de guerlain
le numéro 5 de chanel vous parler en
premier le numéro 5 qui fête ses 100 ans
cette année quand un rendez pas besoin
de vous en parler
non parce que les nombres arrive
toujours ça c'est dans le rif les
nombres arrive toujours à vent et mon
dictionnaire ci avait pas eu la crise
sanitaire aurait dû sortir en novembre
2020 dont baisser même pas fait exprès
mais là c'est vrai qu'avec la crise
sanitaire qu'on a vécu ou le sens de
l'odorat y toucher et même des gens
viennent presque handicapés bible et du
coran des comptes que quand vous perdez
sens de l'odorat vous perdez le goût de
la vie une source de l'odorat saint
saëns capital et on s'est rendu compte à
quel point avec cette crise sanitaire
on était mais lost non pas une transe
les chaînes mais l'os dans la vie quoi
parce qu'on n'a plus de repères parce
qu'on a plus de goût à vivre non des
dépressions d'où des dépressions voilà
d'ailleurs on soigne exactement et on
rééduque le sens de l'odorat aussi il ya
même à garches une entité dans le facto
thérapie pour aider les grands blessés
de la route notamment qui ont perdu le
sens de l'odorat à le retrouver et
retrouver comme ça dépend de leur
mémoire d'encrier dans cette année c'est
complètement lié tout ça est alors
aujourd'hui il ya une offre très
important de parfums évidemment on a
toujours tendance à dire c'était mieux
avant mais bon moi je sens que c'est
quand même un peu des remarques de
vieilles dames et il faut pas dire ça il
vaut mieux laisser le temps c'est le
temps si vous voulez que vous fait
apprécier les choses un classique en
parfumerie il devrait aller
alors il faut le temps et je pense que
les parfumeurs ont toujours un coeur de
créer des beaux parfums
ils ont pas à coeur de créer des parfums
qui vont durer il le soit bien sûr mais
ils vont créer des beaux parfums et
c'est le temps qui décidera de leur
valeur et de leur longévité voilà il y
avait de fait d'un grand merci à l'orge
engage tout le monde à se plonger dans
ce voluptueux dictionnaire amoureux du
parfum c'est un vrai régal
merci et puis l'odorat bah oui c'est le
sens de la vie de la ville qui a été
primordial en ce moment sur tout ça les
personnes qui ont été atteintes du coc
vie dit on peut le retrouver
absolument la sueur ça revient harassé
d'un essai le seul sens qui ne faiblit
pas avec l'âge normalement mais
seulement d'oubli d'éduquer donc muscler
rhône avant la muscler votre bonheur
c'est une super nouvelle
bah oui merci nounou qui longe fesf note
positive a très vite merci nous avoir
suivis et à bientôt donc pour un autre
vie pape
[Musique]